So I get a phone call from my mom and she tells me that my father is about to
get on an emergency life flight from our home in Montana to go to Denver to get
an emergency liver transplant. My mom is kind of perennially optimistic and she's
telling me don't worry it's gonna be okay we're gonna pull through this it's
gonna be alright but I know something is really wrong so I get the next flight I
can to go from where I'm leaving here in New York hoping that I get there before
my father dies and I'm really glad I got that flight as fast as I did because I
was able to spend a couple hours with my father before he passed away and before
I know it I'm at this side of his hospital bed with my mom and we're
sobbing because he's passed. My dad was a he was a strong silent type he was he
was a grew up on a farm and he was the town one of one of two town eye doctors
so he could fix anything you know he could fix tractors or eyes he can you
know no matter what and he was always doing it like behind the scenes you know
he never wanted to take credit for it. It was apparent that my mom and I and my
two brothers were gonna have to be fixing things ourself this time around
and the first thing my mom did was was to call my two brothers one's a year
older one is a year younger and it was gonna be really comforting to see my
younger brother we were really close it was gonna he was really gonna support
me it was gonna be much more complicated seeing my older brother we'd always had
a really complicated relationship and there was something really big about me
that he did not know and that's that the last time he saw me years and years
before I was male he was not aware that I had transitioned from being male to
being female and you know I always wanted to tell him I was trying to find
the right time the right place trying to you know get up the nerve I was worried
about his reaction maybe that you know he was a bit conservative he had a
temper I didn't know how it's gonna happen and I just kept putting it off
and never found the right time and here we are at the time where I have to deal
with all this stuff. Mark wasn't the only one who didn't know my story my whole
hometown didn't know about me either and you know I was trying to find a way to
tell Mark I just kind of figured with my hometown I just I just would never go
back there again so my mom calls my brother and in one phone call tells him
that he lost his father and then he now has a sister and I have to say I mean
Mark was he was really great he he got off the plane we met him at the airport
he gave me a hug but it was awkward as you can imagine and you know I think we
did what a lot of families do at times like that you just kind of fall back on
tradition and we wanted to do something that my mom and dad had always done
every year because you see it was my father's birthday he had passed away 20
minutes before before his 65th birthday so we all went to Applebee's and we got
a slice of sizzling apple pie and put a candle in it and my brother Mark who
really worshiped my father got the honor of blowing out the candle and when he
was blowing out the can I'm still remember the expression on his face he
was you know trying to process my father's passing he was figuring out
why it had been so long that the two of us hadn't talked something that really
frustrated him and it was just all kind of coming together I took a business
card out of my purse it was for this job that Mark didn't even know I had I had
my new name on it and I wrote my cell phone number on it and I gave it to
Mark I said look you know we haven't talked for so long but here anytime any
place no barriers call me anywhere you know we can talk anytime you want and my
mom started crying because her you know her children were reuniting and also
because you know for years she had been running interference between the two of
us and using every excuse in the book to explain why I wasn't getting back to
him or why you know packages to me were being returned because they had the
wrong name on them and if you know her job running interference was over so
Mark was in shock we were all in shock I was in shock because I was thinking
about the fact that you know nobody in my hometown knew and I'm wondering if I
can go back for the for the funeral if I if I should go back if my mom and my
brothers really want me to really deep down and I'm thinking that you know I
never even thought I was gonna go back to my hometown and now I'm being I'm
being pulled back right into it as contradictory as it may seem as soon as
there was a reason to go back I had this really deep strong yearning to go back I
mean I I had gone to school in New York and San Francisco and traveled all over
the world and this place that I thought of as home that I think I've really
repressed knowing that I couldn't go back there right I didn't I don't need
to go back there but as soon as there was a reason for me to go back there a
very strong reason I really really wanted to go I wanted to see the house
the only house I had ever known growing up I wanted to go back to my hometown and
these people that you know comprises community that I thought of as home
right and my mom reassured me that she she wanted me to be there that she in
fact needed me there for support my brothers too and my mom had a plan to get
us there you know our family had been separated for a long time so she had the
idea for all of us to rent a car and drive the 20 hours from Denver back to
Montana so before you know it there we are in the car you know my brother hasn't
seen me for years especially not as female and here we are and we we had so
much to do we were planning we were planning his service my father's funeral
service we were writing his obituary my mom wanted to figure out and I did too
want to figure out how we could introduce the information about me while
still keeping the focus on my father so she had me driving out in the you know
across Wyoming 70 miles an hour she had me take dictation of her friends and she
wanted to invite them over for tea so she had this really strategic list it's
like you invite Judy and she's going to tell all the people in the arts
community that my mom was involved in and you're gonna tell June and June is
gonna tell all the people at dad's office and we'll find somebody else and
she's gonna tell everybody at the church and the next night there they
were 18 of my mom's best friends and the minister from the church where the
service was gonna be performed they're drinking tea my mom says you all know
very well by now that I've lost my husband and I know a lot of you have
wondered what happened to my middle son who seemed to disappear and she said I
want you to know tonight that yeah I have a daughter and her name is Kim and
this is my child and I love my child and I hope you do too and we can focus on
this tonight we can talk about this tonight you all are my ambassadors if
someone has questions at the funeral and I'm caught up in things I want I'm going
to point them to you and let you tell this story because you can talk about it
in a sensitive way and she you know took a couple a couple questions from the
people there and the whole tea party and did slightly different than the tea
party we hear about in the news the whole thing ended with everybody raising
their teacups and saying hip hip hooray for Kim hip hip hooray for Kim there
were a couple amens and some applause and and then everybody went home and I
swear there was a brown out from all the simultaneous phone calls that were being
made dispensing the information right so then the next thing there was a viewing
of my father's body at the funeral home and I had elected not to go because you
know I didn't want the focus to be on me I was going to keep it on everybody and
keep it on my father but my best friend Tim from high school was at the viewing
and he calls me up he had only known the new me for a couple days I hadn't even
told him but he knew me really well and he knew I was chickening out and he
called me from the funeral parlor and he said hey I got a lot of people here
they really want to see you I should probably tell you that the people he's
talking about are the football team because I used to be on the football team and so
applause and so Tim says where are you I got a lot of people want to see you I'm
like yeah I don't want to go and you know I want to keep the focus on my dad
I don't want to be he's like yeah yeah whatever either you come down here or
we're gonna come up there what's it gonna be I said I come up here I guess so
before I know it the football team is at my front door and a couple of them have
cases of beer under their arm one case gets tossed in the snowbank to keep it
cold it's just like high school and all of a sudden they're in my living room
and it's this wake instantly and this show of support for me and for the
memory of my father right and they're in my living room this living room I never
even thought I would see again and people were either laughing or crying
mostly laughing and I remember looking around the room and there's there's
Kevin he was one of the co-captains of the football team with me and I look
over there and there's my brothers Mark and Todd and they were you know we were
all very close in age so we had friends in common and they're telling stories
about my dad and there's I look over on the couch and there's Frank probably
should have all you also told you that not only was I on the football team but
I was the quarterback and so I look over on the couch and there's Frank he's
an offensive lineman it's the job of an offensive lineman to protect the
quarterback and Frank is protecting me once again 20 years later under very
different circumstances and he's got his arm around my girlfriend they're laughing
and knocking back cans of cheap beer and that was the moment that I knew things
were gonna be okay somehow and there was one more person there that night and
that was my mom and she told me something that we ended up repeating
quite a bit that weekend through the services she came up and she said you
know dad was always fixing things and it looks like he fixed this too she said
you know even though your father has died you've been reborn thank you very
much